and thanks Tucker and welcome to Hannity
and this is a Fox News Alert tonight
exclusively right here on this show I
can confirm from multiple high-ranking
DOJ sources who have now confirmed to me
directly the Attorney General of the
United States has not recused himself
from the uranium one issue now that is
HUGE news tonight we'll have more on
this breaking news with Gregg Jarrett in
just a minute plus we are following
several developing news scandals tonight
all centered around one person Hillary
Clinton and that ruthless political
machine that mowed down anyone who
threatened her quest to be the leader of
the free world first we have new
evidence that Hillary Clinton rigged the
DNC during the primary battle and she
basically stole that primary from Bernie
Sanders and the nomination now finally
multiple prominent Democrats are
speaking out against Clinton's
corruption inside the Democratic Party
and also tonight new developments
surrounding Hillary Clinton's dirty
dossier when she bought and paid for
Russian lies about Donald Trump during
the election tonight we will lay out
exactly what laws she may have broken
and why it is now time to start a formal
investigation into her corrupt practices
now President Trump is even calling out
the Justice Department for not
investigating what could be widespread
Russian collusion within the Clinton
campaign and the Democratic Party all of
that and more and tonight's very
important Friday breaking news opening
monologue
[Music]
Hilary Clinton she has been caught
red-handed rigging the Democratic
primary in her favor this according to
former interim DNC chair Donna Brazile
who says she found quote proof that the
Clinton campaign colluded with the DNC
to demolish senator Sanders he didn't
have a chance now according to Brazil
who has a new book coming out next week
Clinton controlled the Democratic
Party's finances strategy even had a
final say on staffing all while poor
socialist Bernie Sanders tried in vain
to take on the Clinton machine now
Brazil wrote an op-ed for political
magazine entitled inside Hillary
Clinton's secret takeover of the DNC she
wrote quote I had promised Bernie when I
took the helm of the Democratic National
Committee after the convention that I
would get to the bottom of whether
Hillary Clinton's team had rigged the
nomination process as a cache of email
stolen by Russian hackers and posted
online had suggested I'd had my
suspicions from the moment I walked in
the door at the DNC
a month or so earlier based on the
leaked emails but who knew if some of
them might have been forged I needed to
have solid proof and so did Bernie
Brazil later goes on to explain her
findings she wrote quote debbie was not
a good manager she hadn't been very
interested in controlling the parties
that she let Clinton headquarters in
Brooklyn do as it desired so she didn't
have to inform the party officers how
bad the situation was how much control
Brooklyn had and for how long was still
something I had been trying to uncover
for the last few weeks by September the
7th the day I called Bernie I had found
my proof and it broke my heart
now that news should disturb every
single voter in America now even some of
Hillary Clinton's former comrades in the
Democratic Party they are now turning on
the twice failed presidential candidate
watch them earlier today we heard from
Donna Brazile that what many people had
suspected for a long time has turned out
to be true
the DNC secretly chose their nominee
over a year before the primary elections
even a
this is a real problem but what we've
got to do is Democrats nail is we've got
to hold this party accountable this is a
test for Tom Perez it was rigged now we
reached out to Clinton's communications
director Nick Merrill for comments about
Brazil's claims now he directed us to
the statement that he wrote on Twitter
that reads in part crux of all of this
bluster about DNC and HFA is Sanders
didn't have the same opportunities to
work with the DNC simply are not true
they opted not to oh really
you're telling me Bernie Sanders had the
same opportunities to control staffing
and strategy and money and the head of
the DNC at the time that lifelong
Clinton allied debbie Wasserman Schultz
give us a break Hillary had a secret
signed contract so what they just told
you is a lie and by the way countless
Democrats must have known that Hillary
had rigged the system and those are the
people that stood by and said and did
nothing and then there's poor Bernie
Sanders he knew now that the system was
rigged and yet he still supported
Hillary Clinton in a general election
where is his backbone and today Nancy
Pelosi dodging questions when reporters
tried to ask her about all of this this
is the highest level of corruption we
have seen in our lifetime every single
person that voted the Hillary Clinton
you should be outraged especially those
that voted in the primary for Bernie
Sanders you were ripped off this was a
stolen election it's a massive scandal
it is now
dividing the Democratic Party this will
haunt Hillary Clinton for the rest of
her life
now this smoking gun story broke just
yesterday but if you turned into your
network news broadcast last night you
wouldn't even know that this story
existed news busters reports today not
one single second of coverage was
dedicated to this story not on ABC CBS
and definitely not on NBC now this
shouldn't surprise us they're all driven
by radical left-wing ideology and
politics is supposed to be fair and
balanced that report the facts now this
is called a bias of omission and it's
the media's favorite
Trek to bury stories that look bad for
their friends that comrades the
Democratic Party but unlike them on this
show we have promised we will expose
truth and we do it every night now
tonight turn to another shocking
revelation from Donna Brazile not only
is she calling out the corrupt Clinton
machine but she also had a few choice
words for former President Obama and how
he nearly bankrupted the DNC she wrote
quote Obama left the party 24 million
dollars in debt 15 million dollars in
bank debt and more than 8 million owed
to vendors after the 2012 campaign and
had been paying that off very slowly
Obama's campaign was not scheduled to
pay it off until 2060 now months after
being corrupted by Hillary Clinton and
bankrupted by Barack Obama the fledgling
DNC is facing it another scandal this
time over a staffing email first
obtained by The Daily wire from a
democratic technology manager now this
email encourages staffers to look for
candidates for some open positions
however the manager then goes on to
write this I personally would prefer
you're not forward literally straight
white males since they're already in the
majority Wow now we reached out to the
DNC and the person who wrote the email
for comment shocking we haven't heard
back this is just one more example of
the Democratic Party they they pretend
that they're an inclusive party for
everybody all while actively now proven
discrimination against people and also
tonight new developments in the real
Russia collusion story and of course I'm
talking about the anti-trump Russian
dossier bought and paid for we now know
by the Clinton campaign and created by a
former foreign spy using false Russian
intelligence all designed by Hillary
Clinton her campaign to use false
Russian intelligence to now steal the
general election just like she stole the
primary from Bernie and that's not all
the Clinton campaign funneled the
funding of this document through a third
party source in order to cover their
tracks but Hillary Clinton she wants all
of us to think this is an on story
because the dossier didn't come
until after the election watch this from
my perspective it didn't come out before
the election as we all know and it's
part of what happens in a campaign where
you get information that may or may not
be useful and you try to make sure
anything you put out into the public
arena is accurate and so this thing
didn't come out until after the election
and it's still being evaluated it was
used by Democrats and people in the
media her statement is just not true it
is a lie on November 1st I'll give you
one example 2016 only days before the
election david korn left-winger he had a
lot to say on MSNBC about the former spy
Christopher Steele and of course this
Trump dossier what salacious lies about
Donald Trump watch this
I met this former the senior
intelligence officer who's really an
expert in specialists and Russian
counterintelligence for a intelligence
service that we all would respect and
learned that he had been sending very
detailed memos to the FBI throughout
much of the summer about based on his
own work that he did with Russian
sources that was indicating that there
had been a Russian operation - for a
couple years now - coop and cultivate
Donald Trump okay it just blows Hillary
Clinton's comments totally out of the
water but to steal a line from Hillary
or so Oh what difference at this point
does it make her campaign still funded a
former spy to put together sketchy false
Russian intelligence in order to smear
the character of Donald Trump and
influence an election and influence the
American people and by the way according
to a brand new report in The Daily
Caller the law firm that Clinton used to
go virtus dossier perkins coie was also
responsible for helping the DNC avoid an
FBI investigation after the servers were
hacked now wonder who debbie Wasserman
Schultz got that law firm recommendation
from how is it that Hillary Clinton
think about this
how does she delete 33,000 subpoenaed
emails bleach pit acid
the servers and then of course use a
hammer on BlackBerry's and iPhones and
why is it Debbie wasserman-schultz
what's going on here she does the same
thing she has an IT guy with busted up
hard drives in his garage and then the
whole thing with the police and the
laptop I'm telling you there is so much
evidence what is wrong with the
Democrats how do they get to continue to
obstruct justice I'm telling you we are
only starting to touch the surface here
this is one of the corrupt most corrupt
scandals that you've ever seen and it's
more than just bad optics
according to Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett who will join us in a few
minutes Hillary Clinton others in her
campaign may have broken serious
election laws you can see them up on the
side of your screen right now and then
of course there's the uranium one
scandal now that put a course on
national security at risk for their
benefit when Hillary Clinton was one of
what nine people to approve the sale of
a North American uranium producer to
let's see the hostile regime of Russia
the bad actor Vladimir Putin giving 20%
of our uranium to Russia when we don't
have enough uranium we have to import
uranium Hillary did this all while Bill
Clinton he got a huge payout from Moscow
the Clinton Global Initiative got huge
donations up to 145 million dollars for
people associated with the uranium one
deal and according to Gregg Jarrett
Clinton may have broken multiple fraud
and bribery laws including wire fraud
mail fraud and many others and let's not
forget about Hillary Clinton's email
server scandal remember mishandled
national secrets top-secret special
access program confidential information
all top secret while she was serving as
Secretary of State well there she may
have broken multiple laws as well these
are very serious crimes they must be
investigated by our Justice Department
and the Clintons must finally be held
accountable for their actions and we'll
talk to Greg cherry and others in a few
minutes to break all this down meanwhile
the president rightly is now calling out
the Justice Department for not
investigating the Russia collusion story
within the Clinton campaign and the
democratic party here's the president
from earlier
I'm really not involved with the Justice
Department I'd like to let it run itself
but honestly they should be looking at
the Democrats they should be looking at
Podesta and all of that dishonesty they
should be looking at a lot of things and
a lot of people are disappointed in the
Justice Department including me now the
president continued Aris frustration
with the Justice Department on a local
radio station let's listen it you know
the saddest thing is that because of the
President of the United States I am not
supposed to be involved with the Justice
Department I'm not supposed to be
involved with the FBI I'm not supposed
to be doing the kind of things that I
would love to be doing and I'm very
frustrated but now the president is
right where is the investigation into
uranium one here is some good news as I
have confirmed at the top of the program
exclusively multiple high-ranking DOJ
sources DOJ sources have confirmed
directly to me that the Attorney General
has not recused himself from the uranium
one issue that is HUGE news tonight now
where is the investigation into the
Clinton takeover the DNC where's the
investigation into the Clinton funded
fake Russian news so-called dossier with
lies and salacious materials to
propagandize the American people before
an election so we need to know where is
the Justice Department on all this will
there be equal justice under the law as
we have been saying we need in this
country and also according to an
interview with cheryl atkinson which
will air this weekend president Trump
believes that this Russia investigation
will result in him being proven innocent
finally I want to end with some good
news tonight which by the way you will
never hear in the mainstream media
because all they care about is D
legitimizing this presidency of Donald
Trump all they talk about is Russia
Russia and Russia for a year with no
evidence right now we are getting the
best economic news we have had in a long
long time something by the way I was
never able to say during President
Obama's administration now since
President Trump took office in January
our economy has taken off in October 261
thousand new jobs created with
manufacturing jobs adding 24,000
unemployment now
is at a 17-year low consumer confidence
a 17-year high and over a million fewer
Americans are relying on food stamps the
best numbers in over seven years
the homeowners rate in the last quarter
has risen and more people are in the
workforce than say seven years ago Wow
and two years ago President Trump he
promised to make our economy great
that's exactly what is happening and
that's only by getting rid of burdensome
regulation hopefully Congress will now
step up and do their job